[Musique]
les travaux de réfection et
d'agrandissement du musée girodet sont
enfin terminés un chantier à 10 millions
d'euros financé à 70% par
l'agglomération montargoise la surface
totale a été doublée grâce à ces
extensions réalisées à l'arrière on
était un petit peu juste
maintenant avec la création d'un nouvel
espace nous avons des salles
d'exposition supplémentaires des bureaux
une bibliothèque des ateliers des
réserves bien sûr est également cette
verrière où nous pourrons recevoir les
mécènes cette nouvelle verrière de 250
m² elle l'atout charme du musée elle met
en valeur le bâtiment d'origine
la ville de montargis doit cet édifice
du 19e siècle à philippe françois d'urzy
un militaire du pays philippe françois
d'urzy était commandant dans les armées
de napoléon 1er en 1811
il avait fait un héritage énorme il a
démissionné de l'armée pour gérer cette
fortune ce qui lui a évité d'ailleurs de
faire la campagne de russie et il est
c'était un homme qui était célibataire
qui vivait je pense modestement et qui a
très bien géré son argent à sa mort en
1851 d'urzy allégués 660 mille francs à
la ville de montargis d'après son
testament les fonds doivent servir à
construire une école professionnelle
l'hôtel d'urzy voit le jour en 1855 à
cette école était adjointe tout amusé
alors tous les étages du bâtiment devait
être utilisé pour mettre sa bibliothèque
y avait plus de 6000 ouvrages 6000
ouvrages pardon et amusé pour mettre
tous les tableaux possédait la ville de
montagne en 1881 l'école à moins
d'élèves et doit déménager dans ce
bâtiment
elle laisse place à l'hôtel de ville qui
restera durant un siècle dans l'actuel
musée un édifice plusieurs usages les
montargois ont hâte de découvrir
giraudet après six ans de fermeture
le chantier a pris du retard avant sa
livraison le bâtiment a subi des dégâts
des eaux avec la crue du loing au
printemps 2016
l'inondation est arrivé un moment où bon
nombre de travaux étaient terminés et il
a fallu reprendre un certain nombre de
choses sur le bâtiment à proprement
parler mais également sur les oeuvres
qu'ils avaient subi des dégâts demain
nous allons suivre deux restauratrices
au chevet des oeuvres altérée par la
crue